Sophia Ricci has no plans to read the
comment section I personally feel like
everyone's a critic and a new interview
with cosmopolitan
the 21 year old model opened up about
her often criticized relationship with
36 year old Scott Disick she had no
problem revealing quote I just don't
care what people think
Richy goes on to explain the public
discourse saying quote doesn't bother me
because I'm very happy
adding why would I let someone from the
middle of nowhere ruin that for me the
end of the day my dream is not to talk
about my relationship with my ex's
family we've also seen tension arise
with their relationship on Keeping Up
with the Kardashians in an episode from
last season things got a little awkward
between Sophia Scott and Kourtney
you're so
[Music]
Ritchie has confirmed to et that she
will not be appearing on the reality
series upcoming new season we did see
you on a certain reality show are we
gonna see I mean fans went seriously
insane for you are we gonna see more of
you next season on that show um no why
not well because I want I want to get
into acting yeah do you feel like
because of who your family is it's
easier or harder to kind of get into the
acting world and be taken seriously um
it's always been my thing kind of
growing up like I kind of felt like I
was stuck in everyone's shadow but I'm
very different from both my sister and
my dad so I feel like I've kind of
navigated into my lane and it's it's
been great for me
[Music]